imagine you can make transactions with
anyone without carrying any cash or
plastic money and without anyone
actually interfering like third-party
applications or banks
sounds like a nice dream right
well it's not blockchain is a
revolutionary technology that has
changed how transactions work it intends
to provide a safe and secure mode of
transactions by using digital
cryptocurrencies that cannot be
manipulated by anyone with ulterior
motives blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transactions to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital ledger that is distributed
across the entire network making it more
secure and impossible to change hack or
cheat the system
then it is verified and validated by
every node in the blockchain network to
proceed with the process of making the
transactions it's cryptocurrency like
bitcoin ethereum and many more that make
use of this blockchain network for
transactions as it helps you keep track
of them as the market capitalization of
the cryptocurrency almost every day new
cryptocurrencies are coming in front and
more and more people are willing to
participate in this revolution of the
economy blockchain is believed to
revolutionize the economy and technology
of the world in the coming future and
like fred sram co-founder of coinbase
said everything will be tokenized and
connected by a blockchain one day
[Music]